[Musique]
il
ya sa place et les maires non
sobh à
wigan est
votée protéine protéine à mais qu'est ce
tu fais pas je mangeais protéines pour
qu'ils posent la question
mettons nous quoi les protéines elles
sont à côté
ça c'est manu
bah c'est pas trop difficile six mois
dans l'espace sans sa compagne
si c'est comme si moi partout sans sa
compagne six mois c'est rien souvent
sans sa compagne 6 mois aux pôles dans
sa compagne et il faut faire des
sacrifices mais ce n'est pas si facile
je suis ozarks avec maxime muscat et on
s'apprête à faire de la tyrolienne la
plus raide de toute l'europe 1km 860 km
heure de pointe enfin tabliers de
protection évidemment un sac poubelle
voilà une cordelette je pense qu'on a
les conditions de sécurité optimales oui
oui oui oui ça comble
je sais pas mais là là j'espère pour toi
oh là là oh là là
là c'est fait à l'arrivée ils te
préviennent pas et en fait c'est un truc
de malade j'ai pas prêt du maxsym on va
voir ce qui lui arrive
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
ouest